[Music]
hi welcome to another episode of cold
fusion
when a company faces an existential
crisis how could the problem be fixed
well they could analyze what's going
wrong consider market competition and
assess their strengths and weaknesses
if done right they might be able to
innovate their way out of a sticky
situation
netflix is sort of in one of those
crises at the moment
one of their recent solutions was to
subtly include gaming in their content
offerings so how is it all going for
them well the first numbers just dropped
earlier this month and well
let's take a look
[Music]
the last time we talked about netflix we
saw how they were losing ip to
competitors losing subscribers and being
eaten by general market competition
these issues have caused no shortages of
headaches for the platform
towards the end of that episode i
mentioned that netflix would have to do
something to turn this all around and
they decided that gaming content was
part of the solution
[Music]
so how does it all work does netflix let
you play titles on your tv with an
existing xbox or playstation controller
no it's a little more simple than that
essentially netflix is supplying mobile
games to their subscribers
on both ios and android the netflix app
has quietly added a gaming section it
features ip from netflix series such as
stranger things as well as other mobile
games that netflix has brought the
rights to
[Music]
when a user clicks on a game it takes
them to the app store or google play to
download the game after this you'll be
able to play that game within the
netflix gaming section or from the home
screen the only difference is that you
get it ad free there are currently 26
titles but the company plans for 50 by
the end of the year
so how is it going so far
well according to new analytics data
published by cnbc in august of 2022 only
1
of netflix's 221 million subscribers are
playing these games
that's 23.3 million downloads but only
1.7 million daily users
a lot of media outlets are calling this
a complete flop but the truth may be a
bit more nuanced
you see looking from the outside this
launch is a bit of a head scratcher it's
pretty safe to say that most of you
watching didn't have the faintest clue
that netflix was even supplying games
the thing is it's been around since
november of 2021 but the marketing was
non-existent
one would think that either they're not
confident in what they're doing or that
it's a purposeful but woefully quiet
launch as it turns out it's the second
netflix didn't want consumers to
explicitly know about their gaming
feature so a figure of one percent of
subscribers using the service is to be
expected
netflix is head of external games greg
peters explains the strategy to cnbc
quote
we're still intentionally keeping things
a little bit quiet because we're still
learning and experimenting and trying to
figure out what things are going to
actually resonate with our members what
games people want to play
we're open to licensing and accessing
large game ip that people would
recognize end quote
it seems that netflix is just
experimenting to monitor human behavior
it appears that when they have the data
they could manage a much more purposeful
launch
so far netflix is utilizing outside game
developers to build out its gaming
catalog but the company has bought three
game studios in the past year and among
them is the finnish company next games
at a cost of 72 million
next games was the studio behind an
existing stranger things title so the
acquisition was a no-brainer
netflix has also reached an agreement
with rocket ride games this hints at a
future of custom netflix gaming content
i spoke to a mobile gaming developer
whose company has been contracted to
work on some netflix content he gave me
a bit of an insider view as to how
things are going behind the scenes
according to him netflix really seems to
be rushing to get things done
they browsed through his company's
catalogue and wanted a re-skinned
netflix series themed version of an
already existing game
netflix said that the gaming publisher
was not to list the app on the app store
and also an anecdote to give you an idea
of how fast they want things netflix
wanted to launch a new game in a few
months despite only approaching my
sources team just weeks earlier a
netflix representative told him that
they're trying to get a mobile platform
together and their tech is in flux and
not quite figured out properly
so it does seem like a bit of a mess at
the moment but we'll see how things go
so the question must be asked why gaming
well it seems that netflix sees their
issues as a matter of user engagement in
a letter to shareholders last year
netflix named epic games among its
biggest rivals for people's attention
tiktok and youtube were also on the list
a senior analyst at d.a davidson tom
forte told cnbc that gaming may be a
method of increasing user engagement
quote
one of the many advantages to netflix in
pursuing the strategy is the ability to
drive engagement beyond when the show
first comes out on the platform end
quote
to this statement i don't totally agree
at best the games only serve as a proxy
for advertising a netflix series the
strategy in its current form doesn't do
much to keep people using netflix
at the moment these netflix games are
still available on the home screen after
downloading them so users can just
launch the game from their home screen
without ever visiting the netflix app
again the tie between games and the
netflix app itself seems a bit weak but
in saying that i'm sure the strategy
would probably evolve greatly with time
as i was just finishing up this episode
some more news broke about netflix
gaming efforts according to techcrunch
netflix has recently posted job listings
that hinted a cloud gaming venture the
openings were listed for a security
product manager with experience in
handling quote cloud gaming challenges
and also a rendering engineer who can
support netflix's quote cloud gaming
service there were also other openings
related to cloud gaming so nothing
further is known about this and netflix
is keeping tight-lipped but this service
if it does come to fruition could be
similar to playstation now google stadia
or amazon luna
so essentially you could play games on
your tv without a console it's
interesting because my source told me
that netflix told him that they were
against doing anything outside their
ecosystem so tv gaming was likely out of
the question but maybe things have
changed and if they're going to build
their own cloud gaming service from the
ground up this would fit their ethos but
we just don't know so we're going to
have to wait and see what actually
happens a million people cancelled their
subscriptions with netflix in the past
three months but the streaming giants
expected to lose twice the number after
years of growth so the company is being
hit by a busier marketplace and rising
costs so consumers are leaving netflix
resulting in its first subscriber net
loss in over a decade
almost a million subscribers left in the
second quarter after a 200 000
subscriber loss in the first quarter
gaming could play a small part in
helping user engagement but really
netflix should focus more on having a
reliable catalogue of native content to
do this is very difficult and capitally
intensive but the content is what people
come to the platform for
right now nobody associates netflix with
games so to change this brand image is
going to take a lot of work and they're
going to have to do a lot of things
right
so what do you guys think do you think
netflix can make a successful pivot to
gaming in the future
or is this just going to turn out to be
a large sunken cost
let me know your thoughts in the comment
section below
if you want to see the previous episode
on netflix i'll leave a link to that
below
also i've been back in the studio
recording podcasts again so if you want
to check out the latest episode of
through the web i'll also leave that
below
anyway that's about it from me
thanks for watching my name is tagogo
and you've been watching cold fusion and
i'll see you again soon for the next
episode
cheers guys
have a good one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
cold fusion
it's me thinking